Solve the absolute value of 3x
minus 9 is equal to 0 and
graph the solution
on a number line.
So let me just rewrite it.
We have the absolute value of
3x minus 9 is equal to 0.
So if the absolute value of
something is equal to 0, what
can that something be?
Well the only thing that you
could take the absolute value
of and get 0 is 0.
So that something has to be 0.
So it has to be a 0 inside of
the absolute value sign.
So we know that 3x minus
9 must be equal to 0.
If this was any other
non-negative value, you would
have two values.
If this was a positive 2, you
would say 3x minus 9 could be
positive 2 or negative 2.
But when you're dealing with 0,
3x minus 9 has to equal 0.
That's the only way when you
take the absolute value,
you're going to get 0.
So then we just solve this.
We add 9 to both sides
of this equation.
You get 3x is equal to 9.
Divide both sides by 3 and you
get x is equal to 9/3 or x is
equal to 3.
And you're done.
And then we just do
the second part.
Graph the solution
on a number line.
So let's graph.
We have a number line here.
Let me draw one.
It's a number line.
I'll put some negative values.
Maybe we'll start negative 2,
negative 1, 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Could keep going on.
But the solution is
x is equal to 3.
So just graphing that on a
number line, we just put a
little dot at 3.